gas cooking stove has exploded in a
train in Pakistan sparking a huge fire
and killing at least 60 people survivors
recorded flames tearing through several
carriages that train was on its way from
Karachi to Rawalpindi which is just
outside of Islamabad Camejo dar is
joining us for an update on what exactly
happened come out and to tell us about
the latest death toll that you're
hearing
well we're hearing now that at least 60
people have been killed and there are
dozens more who have received severe
burn wounds and now most of them are on
the treatment right now the military has
mobilized its Ella copters military
doctors as well to that site this was
the taste calm train of a popular train
that travels between karachi and
Rawalpindi and vice-versa apparently
what we are told is that there was a
group of pair missionaries on board they
were proceeding for a annual gathering
in the city of Lahore and a place called
dry winds where all these missionaries
get together but one of those groups
apparently was making breakfast in one
of the bogies when this accident
happened there was another cylinder on
board also which was the cause of the
secondary fire and because the train was
moving very soon at least four bogeys of
that train when gulped and flames so
indeed abating
all right apologies you seem to have
connection issues with Kamal harder he
was giving us an update on that
explosion on the train that took place
more on that later